harry est l'élève le plus doué de sa
classe hautmont cartel premier prix
c'est cool tu as un trophée qui prouve
que tu es un taux qu'il ne se donne pas
que les avantages j'ai pas fait exprès
néanmoins la chance seddiki toit est sur
le point de tourner tu me comprends
quand je te parle
pourquoi tu parles si lentement s'il
rencontre cody un robot aux technologies
dédiées à la recherche et au sauvetage
formidable invention technologique de la
prend à ressentir
je m'appelle harry en immersion c'est
bien ça alors je vis dame
quelles sont les nouvelles vous verrez
que keller est venu prendre sa raclée
sur pas une cacahuète pourfendre
tout en baisse
je ne jetterai quelque chose comme cody
sa fonction première c'est le sauvetage
c'est de sauver des vies pas les
détruire cette virée
dans les cours on est en danger en grand
danger par le producteur de spider man
x-men et iron man
mais suivant
c
français
ouais je fais quelques échauffourées